et
[Musique]
le marin shadoks est revenu les autres
croient qu'il veut se venger et les
manger et fuit devant lui avec le race
trop loin pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas le marin shadoks et qui pourrait
s'étonner de le voir se prendre l'outil
facilement dans les airs et disons qu'il
avait inventé un système de propulsion
interplanétaire à base d'eau on
l'apprenait à l'arrière pour la mettre à
l'avant voilà tout il venait que tout
cela ne soit très synchronisée parce que
si c'est lyon avait ramène au plus vite
que ceux d'en bas la charia il n'y
aurait plus du dos ou le bateau et il
aurait sombré
inversement si ce duo s'était arrêtée et
d autres pas l'eau serait parti tout
seul et il aurait fallu courir après
mais pour passer au marche arrière avec
ce système là c'était une autre histoire
et en bois laine cela ne marchait pas
dans la marine ordinaire théoriquement
pour aller en arrière c'est bien connu
il suffit d'aller en avant mais dans
l'autre sens
cela s'appelle renversé d'amap on aurait
renversé les shadoks qui servait de
vapeur il n'y voyait pas d'inconvénients
mais il aurait fallu que l'on risque
dont les sauts et l'eau ou des raisons
excessivement obscurci opposer
formellement alors le marin shadoks avec
sacha dope caravelle il avait pas de
marche arrière
c'est des choses qui arrivent même à des
gens très bien mais les
aller toujours vers l'avant je n'ai pas
particulièrement mêmes ils disaient que
cela l'arrangeait parce que de toute
façon ils ne savaient pas où ils
allaient et sa vie faisait gagner du
temps car ajouté tin quand la marine
c'est un principe quand on ne sait pas
où l'on va il faudra y aller et le plus
vite possible
c'est dire que lens qui domine inculque
part c'était tout à fait par hasard et
pas spécialement pour se venger comme
les autres le croyait
depuis le temps qu'ils pour la gay et
bouli nez sur les mers cosmique
il avait été si souvent pris quoi son
qu'il avait oublié tout ça plusieurs
fois par an non non il ne voulait pas se
venger
non les shadoks il ne voulait pas les
manger c'est autre chose qu'il prenait
[Musique]